the biggest thing that's tough when
you're young is reconciling two things
reconciling why you see it so clearly
and not just saying we're young and to
understanding what happens over time you
gotta be up in now
yeah hey new breasts good to see you man
see I like like we've talked and I
haven't seen you in so long
dude the lines and the hair man I need
to really add that to my game I love it
I did I stood I didn't I did it in sixth
grade yeah I was it's hot right now I
mean and I I feel good about it yeah
people either love it or hate it they
either think I'm like it's faded out a
little bit right you did it a couple
weeks ago oh you did what
it's fortunate it's cuz I'm not allowed
to do anything for the show like change
my look so like this is the most I can
do feel like I've controlled myself are
you off filming you're not building it I
got it
it's awesome man since it's it you know
I know him hey man yeah I remember he
showed me you so he watched you thanks
man it's awesome it's awesome um so
what's cooking how's uh how were things
what are you doing I'm doing press for
the show and then you company this
that's stuff you guys were working on uh
and the UH and the show airs when
January 19th this is a season what for
and I come down with an animated show
now - are you the boy sub yeah that's
good that's awesome that scales yeah no
they're trying to so it's it's clicked
that's yeah it's clicks become a
franchise
yeah it's become mustache that's cool
which is like hard so so what can I you
know obviously what I really want to do
is really help you guys obviously we've
had some interactions and things of that
nature and obviously you know we're in
control of all the cameras here so we
don't use anything sensitive so like I
want to treat this like a real meeting
like what what can I help you if let's
start with that um just kind of ice yeah
we're just starting out
we're young and we're trying but we
don't know what what do you want to
happen we want this to be a month
accompany to be the like kind of CAA go
to brand mark like as far as like the
way that people think of it the way that
we kind of produce we want like to have
all the top kind of influencers be going
to us because of our like quality and
because of the way that we as a
production company it's a yeah it's like
a post-op chick I was 14 to background
that's I know AJ I kind of trying to
create Jace like a comparison in the
sense of like a celebrity back company
that's you know has a good face to it
but I want it to be a little bit more
where it's like we're not all feeding
off each other's kind of each client is
managed by by the same person but it's
not they're not dependent on each other
may I take your 1/2 on it separately
engineer the max so kind of a management
style
I understand but the output isn't
management the output is production
content yeah so so management yeah it's
the fact I mean my vision probably
eventually is to become a format the way
the way my pitch it isn't like we're
management I pitch it like like we
connect brands with millions of people
using influencers and we do it the right
way which is not shoving it in the face
it's integrating it right so you're
building a client service business space
yeah yeah good Sam
the thing is like a lot of people a lot
of the clients are do Robert people hard
festers come in and be like yo yeah it's
like full-service manage you so it's
[Music]
branded content traditional celebrities
YouTube more more like youtuber slash in
traditional so your dream scenario would
have been the people behind Will Smith
starting a daily blog or finding like
the Madison beer which is younger and
then growing here in Georgia is now with
the Lexus ran you know what I mean do
you know what those people are of course
yeah so it's like know more about this
world than anybody in the game period
end of story I've been there from 2006
to this moment and out yeah of course of
course
jinke naturally is good at it
we've met what you do from the bean
applause yeah that's the best kind of
you guys it's like there's a lot of
people and you're not one of them but
there's a lot of people who are like in
board meetings trying to like theorize
about like what the kids unlike word in
it we're there I agree so so it's very
very very similar to what we're doing
with vein or talent other than you guys
are willing to do more things than just
produce the content right right yeah do
you guys know what we're doing with
Vayner talent so we have we have Lindsey
Lindsey who was just here runs a
division inside here called Manor Talent
so like Ray Dalio or Michael Ovitz who
started CIA or right right they those
are the two engines behind CIA like
there's people paying us right now
$20,000 a month $30,000 a month to build
out Serge Ibaka from the end be like
we're wrapping up we do a lot of
executives like so we do we do we do
like like I'm living in kind of like
those two places like you'll be more
like the way you pitched it you want him
to have more of a life that looks more
like me I've got he's more of an actual
celebrity came up but I've gone down
about anti-bullying with different
celebrities like Kevin O'Leary's doing
it with him and after scary moves you
try to go like a miniseries on that and
adults doing today's show with megyn
kelly kind of surrounding the dyslexia
angle I'm really trying to build a solid
as more of a personal motive of course
it's right now I think the big thing
that I've been seeing is people that
don't know jay-z know Henry well of
course I want me to learn okay's and I
think that's where that's what we can
start to turn into an executive into a
business sure my business man like it's
kind of kind of contradictory to wear
spandex and red tights on TV and then
you wear a suit I going on CNBC talking
business you're trying to kind of create
that I understand but but the business
thing you're trying to build underneath
I understand so or at least I'm picking
up the pieces I'm trying to I'm trying
to react to the reality of my situation
and and invest in the things that make
sense right like what you guys are doing
or investing and something that makes
that you know where the world's gonna
the world's flipped right and like you
guys know it to your point cuz you're in
it I have the big advantage because I
wasn't in it
but I knew it and all my money was made
and investing in it building around it
like I that's what I've done right
people ask me they're like where would
you come with this idea like it was just
kind of there like it's just I don't I
didn't come up with it I just literally
like saw I think I think the game that
isn't the important I think the biggest
thing that you'll have to think about
specially based on you bringing up
Ronald and your background
and the biggest thing I would tell all
three of you is what they had that we've
none of us will have is the human has
much more leverage than they did in the
past over the next decade yes Jase has
more leverage every day and all these
people Madison and ran because even they
always did but they only had three
places to go and they only had eight
places to be put on what you what your
vulnerability is is but unlimited
competition and unlimited and less ways
to differentiate every kid is growing up
getting it yeah so by the way by the way
just by like and
just by energy I'm like oh yeah bail
they'll build a 10 20 40 million dollar
business which is great but what you
need to realize is every day that it
goes by you lose leverage not gain and
so as long as you're strategizing
towards that it's just more about
becoming the CAA in five no it's funny
when you said when you bring up when you
bring up Madison or rent what's really
super interesting when it's actually
very interesting the moment we had in
our meeting is the most important part
of the meeting you asking me do you know
who they are and me knowing who they
were the day they started is the danger
of your business
well I asked above 22 I pass I get it I
get it but that's exactly right but
we're gonna grow with it ideally no you
can't outpace you're not you're not
gonna outpace it which is okay correct
you could adjust to the leverage right
so presidents and when I found was the
players relate a lot better I'm sure ABA
team is too few people they can relate
ah but it's not but it's not an age
thing right but it's not an age thing
right so if AJ walked in right now and
we would say AJ of the 15 people nine
people that Vayner sports has who are
they relating to relating to the most
he'd say you Gary why cuz it's it's an
understanding relate in relating because
I know more about wills an and they do
like like but like here's the punchline
right like and this is an important
reason I'll bring this up and this is
not to be like I'm cool it's it's I'll
help you it's never gonna be about
anything other than knowing it's like
knowing like like I know no jumper this
podcast matters whether I'm fifteen or
forty to it what you need to do is just
always know more yeah but you're an
anomaly no question like why do you
think I think you can build a 40 million
dollar thing if I was the norm you
wouldn't build [ __ ] yeah that's what I'm
saying in the NBA world you see all
these agents in the I'm sure it's
amusing NFL a guy known under 55 65
weird the players don't like them the
question is can any goofy
the answer is yes you know what see but
you know this negotiating the contract
my eight-year-old daughter can do it you
and me are one of the only pair who's
going a hundred percent in on the social
like these these people they have agents
but this agents actually take a second
you know I totally get it it's it's like
oh you do social media that's could be
able do some social meet stuff but let's
focus on this audition let's focus on
this meeting but of course it's cuz the
economic survey is re-established slowly
how people don't like like it seems very
simple but guess what like when when we
bought cryptocurrency in 2013 nobody got
it
like when I what when I when I bought
Twitter and Tumblr go Jake read it for
me period
like like when you're in when you're in
stuff early and you see the world for
what it actually is you see it for what
it actually is the the bottom line is of
course dude the biggest thing that's
tough when you're young is reconciling
two things reconciling why you see it so
clearly and not just saying we're young
and to understanding what happens over
time what gets commoditized your
knowledge gets commoditized people more
people will know people are starting to
understand like when garyvee on the back
of not entrepreneur magazine or the
planet of the app shot on the back of
instagram and thank you Instagram and
and and YouTube you know like yeah but
like that stuff like that stuff is
everything it's trading culture the
thing the thing that you guys have to
decide as a partnership is what you this
is the best advice the two of you need
to start getting unbelievably real with
each other about how you care about the
next 12 days 12 weeks 12 months and 12
years because that's the only thing that
matters I believe you but both of you
are holding certain things back as you
should it's human nature but no no you
know what you know what subconscious
biases yeah that's what you're that's
what we all do we all respect but no
humans me too but guess what but there's
still other stuff and it's about
anticipation what happens if you fall in
love with a crazy person what happens if
your mother gets sick like I'm talking
everything not like
good you want to feel transparently like
I want to screw him most people don't
want to screw people it's of course so
like to me I think it's super important
for you to think about that because
here's why the business you're starting
now is not gonna be the business you're
gonna be in in three years and
definitely not six and definitely not 10
and the question will become are you
excited about you you have the the
you've gravitated towards loving that
game which I also love I can deal with
people's [ __ ] for the rest of my
life it's innate
to me and that's what doing human stuff
with well if you get into anything that
looks like CIA or William Morris or the
stuff you've been doing or the NBA or
Vayner sports you're in the people
business cool it sounds great right now
but when you're the again to the
greatest Holy Grail tomorrow being the
exclusive social media content provider
and manager of Beyonce you're in the
Beyonce's personality business of course
you are
you're of course you but but the product
is a human now look it takes a certain
temperament and talent to sell human the
real business for you guys is these real
celebrities are about to eat so much
humility and if you can be the people to
tame them from going from a pedestal
down to the trenches to build back up to
a pedestal
it's an incredibly big opportunity see
what I mean you guys are right you're
right you're right yeah yeah I mean look
you know this its proprietary in your
handling of people why why do you think
why do you think that liberties aren't
because for me I was oh here's why I'm
on TV I'm always I'll tell you I love TV
going away the only honest thing is why
are they not more afraid why are they
not thinking they're they're not afraid
because they are afraid but they have
too much ego too the only thing of real
celebrity not you a real a yeah not a B
or C not you not only I'm talking a real
way yeah like the biggest celebrities of
the world who are [ __ ] this up
right is that they don't have the
humility to start at zero that's right
when you are a big-time celebrity for
the last ten years and you have to start
on Instagram tomorrow because you have
to but Will Smith does have the humility
which is why he's gonna [ __ ] dominate
he's still hungry but the person you
know but a million people I'm sure we
can name right now the reason they're
not doing it is they don't like having
5,000 followers that first day because
of course they need it because why go
read the transition of radio to
television of course they brother
brother that's a whole different story
like if you don't give a [ __ ] nothing
matters like you know what I mean that's
fine brother that's that's fun a hundred
percent but you know what kicks in
tasting irrelevance you know the
scariest place right now is to be a
solid B because a solid B is awesome but
it's about to get really not awesome you
it's all the same game brother the same
people you're talking to that I'm
talking to you all see the world the
same way I think the biggest question so
here's the difference between where I'm
at and where you're at and you know I
think it'll be a good thing for you to
debate on the differences and decide
what that means to you as you think
about the next 50 years I have decided
to eat [ __ ] and build these non exciting
ebody businesses like we're talking
right now for one reason because I'm
gonna buy pony or Cracker Jacks or
Captain Crunch take the energy buy
something for 288 million and sell it
for 1 point step I'm gonna do champion
what happened to champion over the last
three years is what I'm gonna do one day
with something corrector do you know
what I'm doing right now is I'm Mike my
brand is as big as it we're as big as
it's ever been
it's as big as it ever has been and
maybe ever will be so right now I know I
want to do entrepreneurship I know I
want to do bigger things I would say
look I would argue it's the smallest
that will ever be popular if you're
bought into where it is right now like
the way you're talking so here's what's
just on the listen listen and that
no no no no listen listen listen listen
it's macro macro it's the smallest I'm
saying I could die for five years
establish myself say I've already done
this company grind grind grind for ten
more years and then get to another thing
I just need to use this juice that I've
got to just throw those two things
understand about two things that's right
like it will get exponentially bigger if
you do this thing the fact I'm not doing
this thing no no I mean meaning like
everything that you guys are talking
about is exactly it's gonna just get
bigger like it's great your your juice
like the bigger you get on Instagram
snapchat Facebook and podcasting is
gonna make you as big as Nickelodeon is
you'll just play off of each other it's
a reason I'm willing to do TV if it's
right Apple one for me before it started
because it was behind a paywall and all
this other stuff
it didn't matter it just positioned me
differently in a world that I know is
dying Hollywood but it mattered for me
in the short term because you're always
just balancing out your game was it was
it about like putting yourself period of
here of course I they I won on the day
of the announcement it just
subconsciously put me on a different
place to the masses right mental health
what do you think about like the whole
celebrity entrepreneurship that cuz it's
kind of happening right now like you I
mean Rob but Elon Musk and like yeah
kind of its cycle helps you
it's cycles its cycle almost like a it's
almost like these people who are created
these are now the news almost yes no do
you know how not famous athletes were in
the 30s and 40s there was a couple but
not collectible the NBA Finals in 1983
was on tape delay didn't show it live
well what's interesting is is now but
now it's not a money game that anymore
now it's so what can you do game like
Elon Musk it's like shake is it a money
game for you yes listen it all like it
all depends on a person Jake couldn't
mean certain oh by the way let me give
you my story this is just true I'm just
saying who's gonna go to I hear two
billion I get it I mean the super
billionaire or the Elon Musk you spent
all this money on Tesla do you know what
I'm saying legacy is always different
than what nobody who ended up with the
most money is remembered something yeah
but but that's because everything's
being
you meant it right that's the difference
now what do you mean meaning like that
was what you're pitching for a while
right that's my biggest belief but you
haven't switched up on that all because
I've been trying to do more like what I
don't like well I just want to make sure
I understand the answer but maybe I just
want to understand the question okay so
for a while you were pitching which is
what I'm doing right now yes no I
consider that creative and I think
that's creative and by the way why not
be cheap the first thing I ever did was
creative why not be TV wasn't me
documenting I did a wine show for 30
minutes
right 2006 reached out to me reminding
you once they want to do a podcast with
James on entrepreneurship
okay oh I should definitely do a pop not
to do a podcast yes you should yes I
look at I look at audio as just so
important that you have to be on it
because it's passive consumption it's
the same reason if I when they go into
sleep or when they're waking up in the
wardrobe when they're driving they're
not [ __ ] wondering Henry James let me
let me give you some amazingly look even
if you're not gonna tension no no you're
half paying attention everything like
it's all the same let me give you a
great piece of advice the written word
audio and video are gonna be here long
after we're gone have been here long
before all of the platforms always
matter they just go up and down in their
report on technology the radio was a
hell of a lot more important than video
you know for a moment there and then and
this and that and so they bounced up and
down the car radio was super important
but having a morning talk show on the in
the car was a monster Howard Stern was a
monster so you've got it goes up and
down do you feel like within the past
year podcasts have just become super
saturated everything gets saturated when
do you think influencers do you think
influencers have become super saturated
but it's supply and demand
the supply is not equal to demand yet
and guess what else happens next talent
rises to the top do you know any social
media guru and businessmen there are
there's a difference between me and them
because I'm more talented than them to
do of course it does go it goes for
everything in life the end yeah there's
nothing else a really sad matter if
you're willing to stick it out dude when
I tell you you'll love this this is
you're done texting I'll tell you
something you gonna love of course can I
tell you what that's called somebody
bought peach beachfront property on at
Malibu when it first came out some man
and woman welcomed her like Puckett will
take a chance now it's still great it's
just way more expensive I was I was on
YouTube in 2006 that was what I gave up
Twitter I was one of the first people
with a million followers that was the
foundation not Twitter's kind of
resurgence because of the politics he
was dying there for a second and now it
all depends on what you use it for but
now it's like the main outs like a main
kind of source for information about the
world yeah I mean it always was it just
it's just it's on your mind right now
because of the politics stuff let me
tell you this though fake humility sucks
oh the other flight [ __ ] [ __ ] I do it
when I know that I'm wearing my your
Jersey and I don't do it when I'm
wearing his mercy I play both which is
weird well I was never nobody knew who
the [ __ ] I was until I was 34 years old
so I was a businessman my whole life so
it wasn't like super hard that was my
first chair that's what's worked for me
so I when you look look look you don't
roll up on Fat Joe and be like of course
you knew who I am but when you're in a
meeting like and you're playing the
exactly but look by the way by the way
this is the wrong answer just keep doing
what you're doing keep doing what you're
doing right and that's it and both by
the way you guys you just had an
exchange that has always been my biggest
issue you both put you just have to both
default starting now cuz you're both
alpha winners and want to win in two we
both we put we no no but no no I've
already I'm watching you guys listen to
me
this is what I talked about 12 days 12
mile
I want you guys to win the fire I don't
give a [ __ ] you you guys you guys do the
we at certain times and you do the I'll
replay the videotape of The Breakfast
Club statement two seconds ago he just
said that's the reason I can get into it
and you said I got you a de bris
brother because it's true it's true his
brand they're both true and the biggest
issue I have with my other alpha
partners is we both think it was us I
think everything that's I think
everything that Boehner Sports is gonna
do is me but it's also AJ like it's do
you know what I mean so like so it's
just so you guys will lose if you don't
fight every day for we and and
understand that truth and and and and
it's B plus a - I'm literally living the
life a couple months ahead of you a
couple years ahead of you that you're
living that's all
that's what being older is good about
you know like now you're [ __ ] set now
you're set he's not yeah you know look
goodbye you come here to you guys I feel
young as [ __ ] but you [ __ ] are young
as [ __ ] you know so listen I'm here for
you guys because I've thought through
these things a ton how do you scale
something somebody who doesn't want to
be not authentic and not like there's a
very specific reason that I'm winning
this thing and I know I'm gonna win it
the most out of anybody it's because
I've been doing it for a much longer
time than most and number two I care
about both I really appreciate it's
really good to see you brah well let me
take a picture
Oh actually wait a minute you got might
wait a minute this is the advantage you
have my daughter watches this [ __ ] I
gotta get something good also getting
them email me that it's good to see you
brother
good to see you
I'm gonna say that
[Music]